brought to you by msi computers msi
number one in gaming find out more at us
msi calm and then of course Microsoft
closed out their press conference with
one of their big franchise we all knew
was going to come Gears of War they said
Gears of War Ultimate Edition it's the
original gears remastered modernized
coming out on august 25th but its gears
of war for that we saw the longer demo
is full they've dropped re all you're
all very cool there's no war happening
it's just kids four of them the good
years for and it starts off and it's a
guy we don't really recognize in a dark
place and then he's with a woman they
are are they the new markets and Dom
yeah we're obvious and Anya marcussen
Tonya yeah but I was playable right from
the get ya took till gears of war 3 4 on
yet ya feel true but here we are it's
very dark right there we see there are
two moons and so I did a little googling
and then according to Gears pedia there
Sarah the planet the gears ticking years
of war takes place on has only one moon
so this is oh no this would be a new
planet well obviously they share some
technology we can see the chainsaws
lancer this shotgun I'm panache sure on
his back looking at very familiar yeah
it looks it looks really really cool I
love I'm just having flashbacks to
playing the first two kids games in coop
and I'm just so excited about it now I
never realized how much I care about
gears until right now like I'm seeing it
again be like man I remember having so
much fun with kids I'm looking forward
to seeing more of it now and I mean
expanded fiction sure why not this is a
talent chance for him to actually try
and tell a better story I mean the first
gears game had of the bunch had the most
interesting story of it because it was
laying out a universe and this is an
elephant of being the origin yeah
exactly and if they treat this in a
similar fashion where they reset
everything and kind of draw a line
underneath all the other stuff that
happened before I until a new gear story
it could be an opportunity to like go
back to that first arrow the first game
and have an interesting story to tell
which that don't touch that these oral
in zobrest like like his face uh in
terms of you know news you were talking
about new fiction we all
so see new enemies so perhaps instead of
you know the emulsion inside the planet
making low ratios made these creepy like
more insectile enemies yeah right at the
end yeah i mean the enemies that we saw
like the foot when they first popped up
i was like wow it looks like Rex from
Mass Effect yeah like I just want to
hear the gear just not like crow good
[ __ ] coming towards the hardest rock
yeah and respect we're in the same you
know it looks just like Rex Oh team
except now except now yeah and the main
character do Tetons he looks just like
BJ blasco it's a bit like remember
people made the observation that wow he
looks like pj but yeah i like the UI
looks similar so it's kind of evoking
the same old Gears of War kind of
familiar feeling graphically it looks
fantastic oh yeah looks I mean the kids
games are always stunning to look at and
chainsawing things is still red
apparently yeah as you can see how are
you guys sad to not see doom style
dismemberment out of these chains oh no
I'm okay I'm okay way right with it ah
and with that tongue party in the gears
of war got the gears for guys face we're
gonna wrap up here our post-show
coverage from Microsoft press conference
2015 at e3 we are going to be coming
back at you in just a short amount of
time let me check schedule here because
we have got the e a press conference
coming up at twelve-thirty thats in just
45 minutes we'll be back with the
pre-show and so please come join us then
get some food or whatever meal time it
is for you right now we're going to go
eat we'll be back to talk about EA here
live from gamespot HQ at e3 2015
you